all right blade Smiths congratulations
you've made it to the third round of
this competition now we're sending you
back to your home forges to recreate an
iconic weapon from history that weapon
is
the boazande sword
Monday sword hails from central Africa
and the tribes of the Congo the short
sword was used not only to wage warp but
also as a ritual object and status
symbol
the more ornate the sword The Higher One
stature and Authority within the tribe
typically African blades have wildly
varying specifications and shapes and
this sword is no different it has a thin
ricasso that flares wide to a leaf shape
from there it tapers to a devastatingly
sharp Point that's built to make Extreme
Cuts and deep thrusts into the flesh
making the weapon a feared and vicious
killer good luck blade Smiths we'll see
you in four days good luck good luck man
[Music]
my name is Ben jennen I'm a project
manager for exterior signs I start
watching forged and fire and it lit a
fire back under me I was like hey you
know this is awesome I need to get in
that part of it still I plan on using
this ADC rv2 I think this would be a
good steal because the abuse it can take
plus it'll hold the finance you want to
make sure that I get all the heat
straight through this blade now I'm
ready for clinch
foreign
I've done that on a million cars and
motorcycles that's second nature to me
so that's going to give my spin on this
and hopefully put me up and above now
I'm ready to set everything up I put the
guard on the blade make sure
everything's where I like it son of a
[ __ ]
I'm getting ready to start doing my
grinds and I noticed something that
looks like a crack
yeah we're gonna have to grind on that a
little bit Yeah grind it down luckily
it's just on the surface you know the
good Lord's looking out for me again
crisis diverted I need to go change my
drawers now
laughs
[Music]
my name is Justin schnot I've been
making blades for 14 years now I just
got my journeyman Smith stamp it's a
rating in the American blades from a
society it means you have reached a
certain level of quality in your work
given the ceremonial aesthetic aspect of
the boson day I'm gonna lean more
towards doing something flashy so I'm
gonna go with Damascus I cut in a ladder
pattern with a grinder and got to get
ready to start shaping the blade after I
get the tip kind of where I want it I
can start working down the blade pulling
that width out
everything looks awesome it's nice and
straight we're gonna let it cool off
here and I'm gonna work on my handle and
fittings if I decide to go ahead and do
a ladder pattern on the guard plate and
pommel plate because I figure it'll be
kind of complementary to the sword blade
I'm making the handle out of Rosewood
which is native to Africa so it would be
relatively historically accurate let's
go see if it'll cut anything
you know I'm pretty confident that this
thing will handle anything that they can
throw at it
that'll do
all right blade Spitz this is the kill
test your bow was on these short swords
look deadly but can they kill to find
that out I will take your weapons and do
some killing slashes and blows on this
pig carcass
then you're up first you ready for this
oh yeah
foreign
yes
all right best talk about your weapon
here
first up the design you have here with a
very aggressive Point lens itself to
thrust all the way through the pick
Argus three times and higher Edge
are sharp but what I find interesting
with your weapon here is there's a
forward weight so it lends itself to be
a good Chopper rather than just a
Thruster over also your weapon
it'll kill thank you
all right Justin your turn are you ready
let's get it done
[Music]
before we stop I really appreciated the
Damascus pattern that you have on here
it's very stunning to look at thank you
now the design you have thrust easily
through the carcass at the same time
creates a big wound Channel with every
thrust and extraction as I'm doing that
now it is a much lighter sword than your
competitors overall sir
it will kill thank you
all right gentlemen test the strength
and overall construction of your blade
I'll be chopping and stabbing into our
Shields over here
Ben you're up first are you ready for
this oh yeah okay great
foreign
got some weight to it it's a bit Hefty
feel that hourglass design is a very
traditional shape for this handle but
that guard with these Corners not so
great for thrusting it's um kind of
chewed a hole in my finger
as far as the edge of your blade goes
it'll lose any Edge at all beautiful
work thank you
do your worst if I was going to do my
horse I'd just slam it on the concrete I
wouldn't do that to you
foreign
that's great handle is very comfortable
as far as the construction goes I think
it's beautiful I think your design and
shape is excellent good job awesome dope
all right blade Spitz this is the
sharpness test the African tapestry
slice
now to find out how sharp your edges are
I'm gonna take your weapon and slash
across these tapestries now unlike the
strength test this is all about what the
edge of your blade does to these
tapestries
then you're up first you ready for this
yes sir
foreign
like hot knife through butter
on the vertical Cuts very easy it's like
cutting air with this on the edges where
it did meet the tapestry it cuts through
the edge is sharp it will cut thank you
sir
all right Justin's your turn sir you
ready yes sir let's do this all right
all right just let's talk about your
blade in fact it's a little bit lighter
makes it easier to control when you're
cutting I'm not worried about the
forward weight pulls me into that
vertical Cuts easy all the way through
diagonal cuts it was easy to cut and of
course as you can see in a horizontal
cut a nice clean line where it cuts all
the way through your head sir it'll cut
thank you
Ben Justin the judge's deliberation is
complete they've made their final
decision both of those boazande swords
exemplify the standard by which all
other forest and fire Champions should
be measured you've both done excellent
work thank you however there can only be
one force and fire champion
that champion is
Justin congratulations you are the
forged and fire champion
Ben unfortunately you're blade by the
most narrow of margins did not make the
cut and Ben Abbott's going to tell you
why
Ben this was an extremely tight race
both of you brought in really beautiful
weapons that performed very well but at
the end of the day your guard bit Dave's
finger
and there was a difference in weight
that made your sword harder to swing and
that's why we're sending you home
Ben please surrender your blade
you know getting this far in the
competition I just wanted to prove to
myself and others you know without a
doubt I have what it takes that is a
damn fine weapon thank you thank you
thank you I came to win it I felt a
little short but hey I'm not going to
let that stop me well Justin looks like
you brought your a plus plus game
because you are the forge of fire
champion and that's a title that comes
with a check for ten thousand dollars
good job my friend
thank you
please present your weapon to the judges
I went into this not knowing who was
going to win but I pulled ahead whoa it
was hard grueling but it was a lot of
fun at the end of the day a little
Bittersweet honestly he's a great guy
we've become great friends but you know
it's competition man somebody's got to
win